[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing you guessed
it monsters
now in the past i've made several videos
discussing various magical creatures and
i almost always refer to these creatures
as well creatures or beasts but today
we're going to be discussing a very
different type of beast we're going to
be discussing the monsters of the
wizarding world that is beasts so
horrifying that they warrant their own
terminology but we're not just going to
be discussing any old monsters we're
going to be tackling and listing off all
the known monsters found within the
monster book of monsters if you aren't
familiar with the monster book of
monsters well allow me to jog your
memory the book properly comes to our
attention quite early on in the story
when hagrid supplies harry with the book
for his 13th birthday
he gives harry the book because it's a
requirement for his third year at
hogwarts more specifically it's a
required textbook for the care of
magical creatures class the book was
written by wizard named eduardus lima
sometime before 1932
and serves as a tome for
magisterologists
however few there may be
known for its volatile nature the book
is exceedingly difficult to open
primarily due to the fact that it'll try
to bite the reader's fingers off how do
we open our books malfoy repeated he
took out his copy of the monster book of
monsters which he had bound shut with a
length of rope other people took theirs
out too
some like harry had belted their books
shut
others had crammed them inside tight
bags or clamped them together with
binder clips hasn't hasn't anyone been
able to open their books said hagrid
looking crestfallen
the class all shook their heads you've
got to stroke them said hagrid as though
this was the most obvious thing in the
world
look
so provided that the book itself is a
kind of monster i can't help but wonder
what lies within
are these monsters as bad as the book
would suggest let's dive into it number
one alazor of westacottus
alazor of westacottus was a magical
creature with a round torso long spindly
limbs large feet large round ears and a
long pointed nose
in my opinion alizor almost looks like a
mix between a goblin from harry potter
and gollum from lord of the rings in the
monster book of monsters alazor of
westacottus is depicted with the snarl
wearing a pointed helmet
2. coco rumsey catcher the coco ramsay
catcher is a small humanoid magical
creature that resembles a cornish pixie
in appearance it's likely that they come
from the same family of creatures not
much can be said of the coco rumsey
catcher other than that they appear to
enjoy picking flowers
number three doralesnov frieza the
doralesnoff freezer was a humanoid
magical creature with large bulging eyes
and pointed ears
i can only assume based on the
appearance of the doralesnoff freezer
that they are somehow related to house
elves and goblins
4. manticore the manticore notably
originates from persian mythology and
was later adopted by the greeks and
medieval europeans
the manticore can best be described by
major zoologist nuke scamander the
manticore is a highly dangerous greek
beast with the head of a man the body of
a lion and the tail of a scorpion
as dangerous as the chimera and is rare
the manticore is reputed to croon softly
as it devours its prey
manticore skin repels almost all known
charms and the sting causes instant
death
the manticore is also referenced by
hermione granger in the prisoner of
azgaban speaking to its savagery a
manticore savaged someone in 1296 and
they let the manticore off
oh no that was only because everyone was
too scared to go near it
i think that the manticore is truly
befitting the title of monster
5. greenwort goth the green wart golf is
in my opinion the scariest looking
creature from this list
in appearance the green wart goth
resembles a sort of devilish looking
troll
it sports long horns on its head small
bat-like wings on its back and
two-fingered claw-like hands
6. hippogriff hippogriffs are likely one
of the only monsters you've actually
heard of on this list magical beasts
that have the front legs wings and heads
of a giant eagle and the torso behind
legs and tail of a horse
they come in all sorts of colors
including stormy grey bronze pinkish
rhone gleaming chestnut and inky black
hippogriffs were dangerous carnivorous
creatures but could be trained by the
right witch or wizard
hagrid discusses the hippogryph in great
detail during one of his lessons now
first thing you've got to know about
hippogriffs is they're proud easily
offended hippogriffs are don't never
insult one because it might be the last
thing you do
you always wait for the hippogriff to
make the first move it's polite see you
walk towards him and you bow and you
wait if he bows back you're allowed to
touch him if he doesn't bow then get
away from him sharpish because those
talons hurt
at one stage in the harry potter books
and films we're introduced to buckpeak a
hippogriff that hagrid introduces to
students in his care for magical
creatures class however buckbeak didn't
exactly have the same relationship with
all of the students
harry for example was able to ride beak
but draco didn't have the same
experience
draco ends up taunting buckbeak to which
he receives an injury completely furious
draco ends up trying to get buckbeak
killed with the hippogriff eventually
being sentenced to death by the ministry
of magic
fortunately buck peak is eventually
saved by harry hermione and the time
turner 7. limax the limax was a magical
creature with a snake-like lower body
frog-like head and four arms they are
known for being able to wield a variety
of weapons at once it's likely that the
limax's name is inspired by genus of
air-breathing land slugs that share the
same name
8. maraf lal dendi
marath lal dendi was a magical creature
resembling a humanoid-like plant with
roots
due to its similarities in appearance to
a mandrake another magical sentient
plant resembling humans
it's likely that they're from the same
family
9. nasal mumps nasal mumps are magical
creatures which resemble both cornish
pixies and the coco rumsey catcher the
most obvious differences are a lack of
wings and a much rounder belly they also
look even more menacing if that's
possible
10. chiliphoras drogodflicarus i know i
said earlier the eliza of westacottus
resembles gollum from lord of the rings
but i think that the chiliphorous drugod
flickerus resembles him even more
despite the wings however there is one
massive distinction here the chaliferous
dragonflickerus is only the size of a
quill this humanoid creature had round
deep set eyes around belly and large
flat feet 11. sphinx you guys must know
this one already that is as long as
you've read the books fantastic beasts
and where to find them published by newt
scamander describes the sphinx as
follows
the egyptian sphinx has a human head on
a lion's body for over a thousand years
it has been used by witches and wizards
to guard valuables and secret hideaways
highly intelligent the sphinx delights
in puzzles and riddles it is usually
dangerous only when what it is guarding
is threatened 12. troll of nadroge the
troll of nadraj was a breed of troll
sharing the troll name along with river
trolls mountain trolls and forest trolls
the troll of nadroge is very similar in
appearance to a mountain troll but
differs in that they possess huge hands
with clawed disproportionately long
fingers
13. valkor
valkors were humanoid-like creatures of
immense size that were able to rip
entire trees out of the ground with ease
apparently a standard valkorm is
approximately eight times the size of a
normal adult human which is scary if we
consider the fact that they are
extremely hostile towards humans
valkors have large heads covered in
blunt thorns thin arms and thick legs
and that's it for this video had you
heard of all these creatures which ones
were new to you
leave a comment down below and as always
if you enjoyed the content please
consider liking the video and
subscribing to the channel until next
time remember
if you listen carefully enough the past
whispers to you
[Music]
you